sixteen years after the Matrix trilogy
ended Keanu Reeves and Carrie and moss
are ready to return to their roles as
neo and Trinity matrix for is officially
a go lana wachowski is back to write and
direct but without her sisters Lily this
time around no word yet on whether
Laurence Fishburne and Hugo Weaving over
will be back to reprise their roles as
well production is expected to begin
early next year
now Yahoo movies actually asked Keanu a
few months ago while he was promoting
John wick 3 if he'd be up for return to
the matrix
Keanu if all the stars aligned and if
the Wachowski presented you with the
perfect script and your schedule was
clear how would you feel about the idea
of returning to the character of neo 20
years later that would be that would be
a gift and be interesting I wouldn't say
no about yeah and how did you go about
getting yourself into the headspace of a
character that you've played so long ago
now you've got put in said three that
you're rolling with but for neo
especially it's such an iconic character
that means so much to so many people I
think when you when you get to revisit a
story and can tell continue to tell a
story you're bringing in the past and
the work that you've done and so for me
it's just kind of placing the emotional
state of where you are who the character
is you know how do they feel how do they
think and then you know putting on the
suit of costume really comes the
exterior that you just feel it job guy
who movie's asking like questions just a
couple months ago and that's thing like
he must have known by then like I think
that's either April or May that never
happened
maybe the deal wasn't signed but he knew
it's gonna happen this was in the works
a yes script was being written so good
acting I can do that yeah it's gonna be
very interesting to see this yes sixteen
years after the the third one I think
everyone can pretty much agree that
second and third movie were not very
good they were great
anything with Keanu Reeves is great they
weren't good I remember the second one
had that amazing action sequence with
Trinity on the motorcycle on the highway
that's the only part that people really
remember like the third one was so
convoluted and complicated yeah so they
really need to simplify the story but
it's also going to be interesting to see
cuz
the matrix really started a new wave in
action film like what they did with the
slow-mo stuff yeah they really changed
action movies so now they like it's
gonna be interesting to see if they are
able to do something that's innovative
again yeah I think if they just do the
same stuff again it's going to be we've
seen that a million times now right so
it's gonna be interesting to see if they
whatever technology wise if they're able
to do something new to really put them
at the point we got a lot of people just
want to invest in Keanu Reeves I think
everyone wants to work with him he's the
it guy right now and I think you're next
right next year right I think they're
shooting it right now so anything that
can Ari's touches right now it's gonna
turn into gold like everyone's just in
love with him so I'm so happy that
matrix 4 is back maybe you're right
maybe it will be different maybe they
have to change it up a little bit but I
think it's great
Genesis I'm living for matrix for Kerry
wants our rami malek to be and he'd be a
great addition to it mm-hmm
kate says I'll only watch the few girl
weaving is that people love that villain
Nelson says countess face seems to have
grown longer LOL mikey says the second
Matrix was so epic the third one goes
straight to the trash can that max is
I'm kind of done with remakes and
sequels they've become way too common
beliefs the original leads are down to
doing it again yeah it's great there go
pull me back but things they're gonna
find like the leather again you have to
it you have to put the leather back on
Keanu Reeves a mother yes yes please